let's evaluate the definite integral
from negative 3 to 5 of 4 DX what is
this going to be equal to and I
encourage you to pause the video and try
to figure it out on your own alright so
in order to evaluate this we need to
remember the fundamental theorem of
calculus which connects the notion of a
definite integral and an antiderivative
so the fundamental theorem of calculus
tells us that our definite integral from
A to B of f of X DX is going to be equal
to the antiderivative of our function f
which we denote with the capital F
evaluated at the upper bound
- our antiderivative evaluated at the
lower bound so we just have to do that
right over here
so this is going to be equal to well
what is the antiderivative of 4 well you
might immediately say well that's just
going to be 4x you could even think of
it in terms of reverse power rule 4 is
the same thing as 4 X to the 0 so you
increase 0 by 1 so it's going to be 4x
to the first and then you divide by that
new exponents 4 X to the first divided
by 1 well that's just going to be 4x so
the antiderivative is 4x this is you
could say our capital f of X and we're
going to evaluate that at 5 and at
negative 3 and we're going to find the
difference between these two so what we
have right over here evaluating the
antiderivative at our upper bound that
is going to be 4 times 5 and then from
that we're going to subtract evaluating
our antiderivative at the lower bound so
that's 4 times negative 3 4 times
negative 3 and what is that going to be
equal to so this is 20 and then minus
negative 12 so this is going to be plus
12 which is going to be equal to 32
let's do another example where we're
going to do the reverse power rule so
let's say that we want to find the
indefinite or
we want to find the definite integral
going from negative 1 to 3 of 7x squared
DX what is this going to be equal to
well what we want to do is evaluate what
is the antiderivative of this or you
could say what is if this is lower case
f of X what is capital f of X well the
reverse power rule we increase this
exponent by 1 so we're going to have 7
times X to the third and then we divide
by that increased exponent so 7x to the
third divided by 3 and we want to
evaluate that at our upper bound and
then subtract from that it evaluated at
our lower bound so this is going to be
equal to so evaluating it at our upper
bound it's going to be 7 times 3 to the
3rd I'll just write that 3 to the 3rd
over 3 and then from that we are going
to subtract this capital f of X the
antiderivative evaluated the lower bound
so that is going to be 7 times negative
1 to the 3rd all of that over 3 and so
this first expression let's see this is
going to be 7 times 3 to the 3rd over 3
this is 27 over 3 this is going to be
the same thing as 7 times 9 so this is
going to be 63 and this over here
negative 1 to the 3rd power is negative
1 but then we're subtracting a negative
so this is going to be adding and so
this is just going to be plus 7 over 3
plus 7 over 3 if we wanted to express
this as a mixed number 7 over 3 is the
same thing as 2 and 1/3 so when we add
everything together we are going to get
65 and one-third and we are done